foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar AI
powered AMR detection and surveillance
to inform antibiotic Precision therapy
I am Kaylee Bach of labyrts and I'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by option
options portfolio includes services and
solutions for outbreak surveillance
infection prevention and control AMR
prediction and the targeted delivery of
antimicrobial therapy to learn more
visit optgen.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
and with that I'd like to now welcome
our speaker Dr Arnie materna CEO of Eris
genetics and opgen Group Company
Dr materna welcome you may now begin
your presentation
hello and welcome to today's seminar my
name is Anna materna I'm the CEO and
managing director of Aries genetics I
have the pleasure today to review
together with you the benefits and
utility of whole genome sequencing for
Hospital surveillance and infection
prevention and control and to explore
how recent advances in technology can
help clinicians adopt this technology
into the routine
a few words up front about Aries
genetics Aries is a subsidiary of option
a company developing Ru and FDA cleared
solutions for molecular infectious
disease and AMR testing
under the Aries brand our teams develop
and commercially offer Next Generation
genome sequencing and bioinformatics
solutions to advance the prevention the
containment and care of patients
suffering from Health Care Associated
infections
with fully operational NGS service
Laboratories in Rockville Maryland and
in Vienna Austria we offer genome
sequencing based testing to customers in
the US and in Europe and bioinformatics
software globally
but now let's move ahead and review
today's agenda I will start with a brief
overview over a health over Health Care
Associated infections or Hai for short
we'll review their impact and the
resulting importance of Hospital
surveillance
in the second section I will introduce
whole genome sequencing abbreviated wgs
throughout this presentation as a new
solution with vastly improved properties
when it comes to near real-time outbreak
detection and infection prevention and
control
we will together review a few recent
studies of wgs for Hospital surveillance
with a special focus on the patient and
the health economic benefits that the
various study authors have reported
concluding we will discuss barriers for
adoption of all genome sequencing into
the clinical routine and present recent
technological advances and solutions
that lower the adoption barriers and
enable hospitals to move forward with
implementing wgs
let's begin with a short overview of
healthcare-associated infections or
abbreviated Hai
hais are predominantly caused by the
so-called Escape pathogens comprised of
enterococcus facium staph aureus
klebsiella pneumoniae acetobacterial
balmainii and pseudomonas eriginosa
other relevant and increasingly
problematic pathogens include for
instance E coli Clostridium difficile or
candida aureus what makes these
pathogens particularly problematic is
that they tend to escape antibiotic
therapy by developing an acquiring
resistance to Common and even last
resort antibiotics
some of the common causes for Hai
include Central Line Associated
bloodstream infections
cathedral-associated urinary tract
infections surgical site and wound
infections or ventilator-associated
pneumonia
hais already are among the top 10 causes
of death impacting one in 31 hospital
patients and one in 43 long-term acute
care patients
what is also important to know about
hais is that these infections are
preventable through a timely hygiene and
infection prevention and control action
which sadly makes hid primary cause of
preventable death
in the U.S about five percent of all
Hospital admissions result in Hai cases
which are caused as you can see here in
the pie chart on the right predominantly
by surgical side infections ventilator
Associated pneumonia central line
Associated bloodstream infections C diff
and catheter-associated urinary tractor
infections these cases then impact
Hospital budgets by increasing the usual
length of Stay by on average 17.6 days
which is costing U.S health U.S Health
Care Systems annually something in
between 28 to 33 billion US dollars in
excess Healthcare cost
if you're involved in healthcare or
Hospital Administration then I am sure
you would immediately find many good
alternative uses for these expenditures
but even more important than cost is
that the 722
000 registered cases of Hai each year
lead to over 90 000 deaths that is 250
deaths per day in the us alone
and during and during covet this number
grew by 15 year on year
in Europe the numbers look no different
with seven percent of all patients in
acute Healthcare facilities Contracting
Hai leading to 35 000 deaths per year
that's another 100 per day and estimated
16 million additional Hospital days each
year causing Nexus Healthcare cost of
roughly 7 billion euros annually
since hais can be prevented by Hospital
surveillance informing a timely hygiene
and infection prevention and control
action these numbers suggest that the
current standard approach to hospital
surveillance is inadequate
let's therefore take a closer look on
routine Hospital surveillance carried
out today
Hospital outbreak detection
investigation and control follows a
paradigm that essentially in many places
is unchanged from the methodologies
described by Jon Snow who in the mid
1800s conducted a series of
Investigations of Cholera outbreaks in
London both to discover the cause of the
disease and to prevent its recurrence
snow relied for his studies on
observations of disease in a geographic
and a temporal context to infer outbreak
activity and disrupt the source of the
disease which for cholera were some of
London's water sources
in today's hospitals daily surveillance
is undertaken for patients who are
positive for pathogens of particular
importance
the detection of two or more patients
were positive for the same indicator
organism is investigated using Hospital
databases Ward visits Etc in order to
determine whether cases have overlapped
in time and place and to identify any
other factor that could link them
all of the available information is then
reviewed manually to assess the
probability of an outbreak and the need
for either further investigation for
example the screening of other patients
staff or equipment
or for interventions for example through
enhanced infection and control measures
hygiene routines or cleaning
the problem with this approach is that
factors such as time and location can be
circumstantial leading to cases when
Healthcare Associated infections which
require
urgent infection prevention and control
action
and cases of community acquired
infections which do not require any
action cannot be told apart
this is where methods for pathogen
typing come into play
these methods establish genomic
relatedness between individual pathogens
that were isolated from patients
related isolates are a much stronger
indicator of the observation of a new or
active outbreak cluster
the issue with most typing methods
however is twofold
genotyping can be slow especially when
samples have to be first collected and
sent to partner Labs or research
collaborators
also most methods such as pulse field
gel electrophoresis Spa typing or mlsd
which are all widely used
consider only a very limited number of
genomic markers or locations
therefore these methods suffer from a
poor resolution for isolating and
discriminating outbreak clusters and
transmission chains in the data
and to be clear data that come two or
more weeks after collection and that
cannot resolve outbreak clusters well
do lose their value for guiding
infection prevention and control action
here whole genome sequencing essentially
represents a paradigm shift in hospital
surveillance
via this approach each case of a
surveillance critical pathogen is
submitted to sequencing which is the
only method that offers a type of
relatedness analysis that is
scrutinizing and comparing the entire
Genome of each isolate with single
nucleotide level resolution
as a result low resolution typing data
in any subjective guess work on
relatedness is essentially replaced with
an objective measurement of relatedness
or distance between current and past
cases
the advantage over traditional or even
molecular typing methods hereby
is that the process of detecting cases
belonging to new or already active
outbreak clusters can essentially be
automated
and in addition whole genome sequencing
provides highly resolved transmission
chains which make the identification of
effective hygiene and infection control
interventions much more straightforward
whole genome sequencing is thereby not
less but rather more sensitive or
specific than other methods
what has always intrigued us about whole
genome sequencing and the reason why the
Aries team at option is fully focused on
sequencing as a core technology
is that the method can provide accurate
information on passage and ID
antibiotic resistance
genomic relatedness outbreak clustering
and pathogen transmission all in a
single assay
and thanks to the continuous innovation
of NGS platform Technologies both cost
and turnaround times have substantially
decreased with as little as four to six
hours turnaround time clinical
microbiology Labs with Advanced NGS and
bioinformatics capabilities already
in-house can in theory today enable same
or next day reporting
here an example of a process for whole
genome sequencing based outbreak
detection as implemented into Healthcare
settings at the University of Pittsburgh
medical center by a team of researchers
led by Dr Alexander Sunderman
in this model every clinical culture
from a patient infected for instance
with acetobacterial species pseudomona
species extended Spectrum B delectomase
producing escherichia coli eclepsiella
and a range of other indicator organisms
were submitted to whole genome
sequencing if certain inclusion criteria
for hospital admission and observation
dates were met
if whole genome sequencing then revealed
a new or active outbreak cluster for any
of the patient isolates and if the
transmission Route could be
bioinformatically established the
infection prevention and control or
abbreviated IPC teams were notified
immediately
if transmission routes could not be
resolved for example due to the number
of cases still being too sparse the
epidemiologists would first review the
relatedness patterns in the context of
the information in the medical record
before reporting to the IPC team
it is of note that a substantial part of
the interpretative wgs or whole genome
sequencing process
can be automated or at least Guided by
bioinformatics software
critical hereby is that the software has
to be accurate and ideally validated
easy to use
that it offers rapid turnaround times
regardless of sample volumes and that
the software ensures that the data are
both safe and securely backed up
that it acts in compliance with data
privacy regulations such as the HIPAA
Act
and last but certainly not least
that the information is condensed into a
format that is conducive to action by
IPC experts
I'm now Switching gears as we will
review a number of recent studies to
assess the patient and economic benefits
in other words the clinical utility of
implementing whole genome sequencing for
routine Hospital surveillance
I'd like to start with a study conducted
by the aforementioned team in Pittsburgh
led by Dr Alexander Sunderman
in a study published in 2020 by Kumar
and co-workers the authors
retrospectively analyzed whole genome
sequencing data gathered between 2011
and 2016 from 11 Hai outbreaks involving
89 patients
the researchers bioinformatically
assessed relatedness and establish
transmission Networks and then use these
data to model the impact that whole
genome sequencing would have on
disrupting Hospital transmissions and on
reducing mortality if routinely applied
the author's predictions are shown in
the table on the right hand side of the
slide and led to the conclusion that
Transmissions could be reduced by more
than 45.7 percent and mortalities by
51.7 percent
interestingly the cost of whole genome
sequencing projected by the model were
outweighed by the savings due to the
reduced hospitalizations and excess
Healthcare cost leading to an overall
saving rather than a cost
probably encouraged by these predictions
Dr Sunderman and his team further
refined their process for whole genome
sequencing based outbreak detection and
embarked on a study published in 2021
which retrospectively analyzed whole
genome sequencing data and Associated
medical records for
2752 patients
the team then compared the outputs of
their whole genome sequencing process to
the standard of Care at the local
hospital to project health and economic
benefits of whole genome sequencing
the observations again shown on the
right confirmed their earlier findings
first the diagnostic yield for detecting
outbreaks and as well as implicated
patients was drastically increased
through wgs
even when considering that the standard
of care results excluded colonizations
which makes this a bit of an apples to
oranges comparison it can be safely
assumed that the standard of care misses
many incidents of ha outbreaks
overall the study predicted a reduction
in Transmissions
Associated 30-day readmissions and
mortality
remarkably and driven by the reduced
hospitalization healthcare costs due to
Hai cases the net savings per detected
transmission event were estimated to be
as high as 10 900 US dollars per case
the officers the authors also
communicated at a turnaround time of
roughly two weeks
appeared to be sufficient for the local
IPC teams to sustain a reduction in
transmission events at the clinic
the projected economics
here shown by the upper and lower
estimates for net savings depending on
the number of detected transmission
events
impressively demonstrated that whole
genome sequencing regardless of the
number of cases makes sense purely from
a cost perspective
an argument in favor of whole genome
sequencing that is made even stronger
when considering the patient benefit and
the method's ability to reliably
identify outbreak clusters
here shown in the center of the circular
dendrogram and to effectively
discriminate them from the periphery of
community acquired infections
and to do so universally across critical
pathogens
for the third study we shift our Focus
to Australia and to a group that has
expanded the focus of their
investigation from the local hospital to
the regional Healthcare level
the research teams of David Patterson
and Patrick Harris at the University of
Queensland in Brisbane conducted a
thorough analysis of the budget impact
of routine whole genome sequencing based
surveillance of six critical multi-dog
resistant pathogens at 27 hospitals
across the Australian state of
Queensland
in order to generate a solid data
foundation for their analysis the teams
conducted prospective whole genome
sequencing outbreak analysis for two
years and collaborated with a team of
healthcare economists familiar with the
local cost of care
before we dive into the details a little
spoiler up front the study published by
first author Louisa Gordon in 2021
concluded that whole genome sequencing
surveillance leads to a Statewide
reduction of hai-associated deaths of 32
percent
a reduction in colonized patients of 38
and a net reduction of Hai Associated
health care costs of 18 percent
the findings we will now review have
compelled the state government to
support the implementation of routine
whole genome sequencing to the tune of
25 million Australian dollars
as I already mentioned the team
collected data from 27 hospitals and
considered the entire state of
Queensland the second largest and third
most populous in Australia for their
analysis
the costs were modeled based on costs
for hospitalizations sequencing and
epidemiology action
the Assumption on Hai incidents
considered the annual hospitalization
rates the point prevalence for Hai in
Australia which is just shy of 10
percent
and the multi-drug resistance rates and
their trends
the costs were then aggregated for the
state of Queensland based on the
expected number of multi-drug resistant
isolates arising in Queensland hospital
patients given the point prevalence
the surveillance data for this study
came from a two-year research
demonstration project of prospective
whole genome sequencing for isolates of
suspected outbreaks
the interventions compared by the
authors were whole genome sequencing
versus the standard of care for MDR
pathogens
an implementation of whole genome
sequencing was assumed for six common
multi-drug resistant organisms including
methicillin-resistant staph aureus
extended Spectrum beta-lactamase
producing E coli
Vancomycin resistant androcluspasium
espl producing klebsiella pneumonia
carpentamase producing androbacterialis
and carbopenum-resistant
acinotobacterial palmoni
the study compared the following primary
and secondary outcomes for both
interventions expected Hospital costs
counts for patient infections and
colonization and deaths from bloodstream
infections
the authors have actually calculated
cost annually across five years from the
base year 2020 onward but for Simplicity
I only highlight here the impact of year
one of whole genome sequencing
the study findings projected that in
year one when only relying on standard
of care testing 97
539 patients in Queensland were expected
to be infected or colonized with one of
the six multi-drug resistant pathogens
a timely infection control measure is
informed by whole genome sequencing
surveillance could avoid 36
726 infected or colonized patients and
avoid 650 deaths
these numbers which are highlighted here
in green on the right hand side table
deliver I think a very clear message
about the patient benefit that can be
realized through routine whole genome
sequencing surveillance
moving on from the patient benefit to
the economics let's take a look at the
impact on Healthcare cost next
the total cost under the standard of
care was
170.8 Million Australian dollars in
2021.
whole genome sequencing surveillance
costs an additional 26.8 million
Australian dollars which however was
offset by reduced costs for cleaning
nursing personal protective equipment
of course also shorter hospital stays
and reduced antimicrobial treatments
leading to an overall cost saving from
whole genome sequencing surveillance of
over 30.9 million Australian dollars in
year one alone
in summary the authors established that
whole genome sequencing surveillance
provides a clear benefit to patients as
well as to health economics
to demonstrate that these findings are
rather reliable
um the authors also conducted a
sensitivity analysis which showed that
these cost savings remained when input
values were varied at 95 confidence
limits
the last study I'd like to present was
published almost exactly one year ago
and conducted by Dr Norrell Sherry and
co-workers at the University of
Melbourne in the Australian state of
Victoria
also here the authors investigated in a
prospective multi-center study the
implementation of whole genome
sequencing surveillance regionally
across eight hospitals
to do so
2275 isolates were collected from 1970
patients unsequenced and again the focus
was on Hai pathogens in particular on
Vancomycin resistant intracoast facium
extended Spectrum beta-lactamase
producing E coli and klebsiella
pneumonia
out of these
2275 isolates
844 were implicated by whole genome
sequencing as genetically related
354 of these cases were likely to be
caused by Healthcare Associated
infections with all the consequences to
Patient well-being and Healthcare cost
we have just learned about
another 253 of these cases were possibly
linked to Hai and only 263 were unlikely
to be caused by Healthcare Associated
infections
this data set again underlines the
pervasiveness nest of healthcare
Associated infections and the
shortcomings of the current standard of
care for Hospital surveillance across
hospitals and networks also in highly
developed areas of the world allow me to
be blunt at this point but anyone
believing that their hospital is not
suffering from hais Simply suggests that
they are not looking at the expense of
patients and payers
what I do find interesting about the
Melbourne study in particular is the
perspective on whole genome sequencing
from an epidemiologist's point of view
the team found for instance many
unexpected Transmissions warranting
interventions that were specific to only
certain words
they also emphasize the distinct
advantage of whole genome sequencing in
detecting Hai clusters and Transmissions
that would have been complicated to
identify with traditional epidemiology
epidemiological analysis
and they
conversely stress to cost and
stewardship advantage of reducing IPC
interventions where whole genome
sequencing could confirm that cases were
unrelated and caused by community
acquired as opposed to healthcare
Associated infections
learnings at the regional level included
that incidence of related VRE
Transmissions were higher in some
hospitals than in others justifying
hospital-specific action or changes in
hygiene
also the team found that mdro infections
that were previously considered
community acquired were actually related
providing evidence for previously
unrecognized Hai outbreaks
finally the fact that 86 percent of his
were caused by vres
was able to inform changes in public
health policies at the state level
another aspect that is often overlooked
and that the authors of this study
explored further is how the rather Rich
information by provided by genomic
relatedness analysis in the form of
dendrograms for instance can be
condensed into reports that IPC teams
can act upon
in their example they share with
infection prevention and control or IPC
as little as an alphanumeric sequence
type for each isolate
and a color-coded traffic light
indicator to classify genomic
relatedness into high suggesting likely
transmission between the listed patients
medium potentially warranting further
manual investigation under consideration
of the patient record
and likely unrelated essentially
advising against IPC action
so summarizing so far hais are the
primary cause of preventable deaths
among hospitalized patients
whole genome sequencing surveillance of
isolates can confirm or refute
epidemiologically LinkedIn factors
pathogens thereby and thereby discover
new outbreaks or incidents of active
known outbreaks
in the same essay whole genome
sequencing can accurately confirm
pathogen ID
discriminate between different strains
classify novel pathogens and more
whole genome sequencing surveillance
when adopted into the clinical routine
saves lives and has the potential to
reduce Hai incidence by up to 70 percent
finally the cost effectiveness of whole
genome sequencing for Hai surveillance
has been demonstrated at the local and
Regional level in robust independent
retrospective and prospective
multicentric studies
if we consider for a moment the
definition of clinical utility of an
intervention
which is defined as the patient benefit
divided by the total cost of care
then these four studies we just reviewed
all suggest a high clinical utility
of whole genome sequencing and establish
a favorable value proposition for
adopting passage and whole genome
sequencing into routine clinical
practice for surveillance
which brings me to the final section of
this seminar in which we discuss
technological advances and solutions
that help Healthcare Providers
accelerate the adoption and
establishment of whole genome sequencing
surveillance
let's review some of the challenges that
can complicate the adoption one barrier
is technology access
hampered by a lack of local capacity for
whole genome sequencing
to build local capacity clinical
microbiology Labs need to expand the
Capital Equipment cost to bring NGS
platform technology in-house and to
bring on board train stuff which is
something that has been in short supply
since covet 19.
even with technology and stuff on site
establishing and validating laboratory
developed tests is at least initially a
burden
another very important factor is
turnaround time
whole genome sequencing surveillance
workflows have to be able to inform IPC
action within no more than two weeks
after sampler collection and ideally
faster
especially when first adopting a whole
genome sequencing surveillance and when
the number of samples per run can still
be low running NGS platforms below
capacity to meet turnaround time
requirements can again result in higher
pre-sample costs
it goes without saying that any clinical
test or intervention has of course to be
validated and reliably offer accurate
performance
which for whole genome sequencing is not
only a matter of the wet lab workflow
but especially is is if is of is
especially of importance for
bioinformatics and data interpretation
and actionable Reporting
setting up and maintaining
bioinformatics in a way that fits into a
clear environment traditionally requires
specialized personnel and access to
scalable compute Hardware which is
driving up the total cost of ownership
continuously generated by the need for
bioinformatics
depending on bioinformatics of course
also comes with the burden of ensuring
that any tools that are used comply with
data privacy protection and patient
confidentiality standards such as HIPAA
our r d and Aries product development
efforts at Option therefore focus on
lowering these barriers to adoption in a
nutshell we enable enhanced surveillance
for detection of microbial outbreaks in
healthcare facilities
by providing validated whole genome
sequencing services and comprehensive
genomic analysis that enable earlier and
more sensitive identification of
outbreaks in order to prevent in
facility transmission sooner and reduce
Hai AMR and their impact on patients in
healthcare
we distinguish between full service and
Analysis only
full service for isolate sequencing
dubbed Aries ISS includes sample
processing and whole genome whole genome
sequencing using workflows that we have
fully validated following clear
guidelines for both short and long-rate
sequencing platforms
our process is streamlined to offer
short turnaround times of as little as
five business days in certain
geographies
and to facilitate sample collection we
provide kits along with detailed
instructions and everything required for
safe collection storage and express
shipping of clinical isolates to our
facilities
we thereby recognize that sample
collection procedures can differ from
hospital to hospital for example some
use lands instead of plates for storage
and shipping and our teams are fully
prepared to customize sample collection
to best fit your process
full service also includes data analysis
including passage and ID and typing
outbreak cluster detection as well as
comprehensive genomic characterization
of AMR plasmids and virulence markers
unique to Aries technology and another
benefit We Believe for team clinical
whole genome sequencing can enable is
the machine learning power prediction of
phenotypic susceptibility and resistance
to antibiotics directly from genomic
data
such antibiograms generated through this
proprietary process we refer to as
genomic AST are therefore routinely
incorporated into our isolate reports
all data results and reports in addition
to interactive tools for outbreak and
transmission analysis are accessible via
the Aries Cloud Web application
and just like for sample collection our
team will work with your IPC and
epidemiology Specialists to customize
the reporting and ensure a seamless
integration into your clinical workflows
for data processing
the analysis only option
um is delivered via the web application
Aries cloud Aries cloud is an easy to
use fully featured Standalone software
that is designed to supply clinical
microbiology Labs with in-house MGS
capacity with validated fast scalable
and secure analytics and with all the
data interpretation and Reporting
features that full service customers
enjoy
this slide provides an overview over the
different Aries services that option
service labs are currently offering
including Aries ISS the service we just
described for Rapid isolate sequencing
and the focus of today's presentation
but we also offer Aeris ISP a
comprehensive Target enrichment panel
for environmental AMR surveillance which
screens for over 14 000 AMR markers
included in the rsdb database
and Aries ID and amplicon sequencing
service for the cultural free
identification of pathogens with species
level resolution directly from patient
specimen
to fully leverage the potential for
Rapid turnaround times of real-time long
read sequencing using nanopore
technology we have validated RS ISS not
only on the current de facto standard
Illumina but also on sequencing devices
provided by Oxford nanopore Technologies
these platforms have properties that
make them ideal for infectious disease
applications
sequencing on ont is performed by
translocating long DNA strands through
biological pores and across the membrane
different electrochemical properties on
either side of the membrane lead thereby
to a measurable electrical current
through the pore
and this current changes depending on
the sequence context as DNA single
strands pass through the pore creating
thereby electrical signals that can be
converted into a sequencing readout
advantages of this technology include
for instance that sequencing is
performed in real time on platforms that
do not require any complicated onboard
liquid handling or Optical sensing which
significantly reduces platform costs and
importantly also NGS runtimes down to as
little as a few hours
like all area sequencing Services also
RS ISS has been fully validated
following clear guidelines
and to help clinicians adopt whole
genome sequencing into their local labs
we determine diagnostic performance of
our assays typically in multi-centric
studies and we publish not only the
performance results but also the
validation protocols including the
reference materials we used
shown here on this slide are the
validation results for isolate whole
genome sequencing via RS ISS and Aeris
cloud
and as you can see pathogens were
identified and typed as required for
outbreak analysis with the highest
sensitivity specificity and
reproducibility
Aries cloud has been designed to
facilitate rapid whole genome sequencing
run data interpretation in under one
hour through a software that scales to
any sample throughput at low and
importantly at predictable cost to the
hospital or the laboratory
data analysis after data upload is fully
automated and requires zero user
intervention and Aries Cloud provides
actionable reports and easy to use
outbreak analysis features for
relatedness and transmission analysis in
the context of EHR metadata
all bioinformatics pipelines have been
fully validated and allow clinical
microbiologists to comprehensively type
and characterize pathogens
predict AMR
and to detect and explore outbreak
clusters and transmission events at the
highest possible resolution
before I conclude the presentation I
would like to digress for a couple of
minutes and invite you to join me to an
Excursion into capabilities Beyond
outbreak detection that whole genome
sequencing can offer when coupled with
AI and predictive modeling
foreign
core to the analytical capabilities that
Aris teams have been developing since
2017 is a microbial database we've refer
to as rsdb
rsdb hosts over 130 000 carefully
selected and curated clinical pathogen
genomes and what makes this database
stand apart from other genome databases
is that for each isolate genome also the
associated phenotypic antibiotic
susceptibility testing or AST
measurements have been obtained under
control lab conditions
the resulting data sets of associated
genome on one hand and amorph phenotypic
information on the other hand
can be mined for previously unknown
biomarkers for AMR leading to a
comprehensive selection of well
annotated genes and mutations associated
with antibiotic resistance
but the main purpose of these data sets
is to serve as training data for machine
learning models to predict antibiotic
susceptibility
or in other words how a given microbe
would behave when exposed to different
antibiotic compounds
unlike rule-based approaches as used by
rest finder or AMR finder our AI models
do not depend on simple presence absence
of known genetic markers alone but allow
for polyvariate sequence signatures
including for instance in non-coding
regions that may affect gene expression
the machine learning approaches we have
chosen and optimized over the years rely
on a process referred to as stacked
Ensemble modeling
instead of only learning sequence
signatures like Gamers that are
predictive of phenotypic AMR these
algorithms can associate AMR phenotypic
data with a whole stack of sequence and
sequence derived information such as
amino acid information Gene and genome
structure and Symphony or mutation
impact scores
considering also information that is
more robust to sequencing errors makes
these models essential out of the box
highly accurate for different NGS data
types which is one of the reasons why we
see highest accuracy across all
sequencing Technologies we have
evaluated and validated which include
Illumina Oxford nanopore as well as pect
biome
we've shown in a recently published
paper that these models can with only
minor modifications even be applied to
metagenomic sequence data and still
predict susceptibility with a balanced
accuracy of 90 and with major and very
major error rates Superior to those of
rule-based approaches
the performance of these genomic AST
models has not only been evaluated by us
in-house but also by our clinical
collaborators in numerous studies
since the original multicentric clinical
study which has been assessing the
performance of Aries genomic AST in the
context of isolates collected from
respiratory tract infection patients
highlighted here in red on the left hand
side of the graph
several collaborators have explored a
number of complex and edge cases
for instance studies performed at Mayo
explore genomic ASD in E coli
bloodstream infections and acid and
tobactrobarmonia infections or a study
conducted at Johns Hopkins investigated
genomic ASD model performance in
carbopenum-resistant androbaccriasis
which however were negative for the
resistance conferring carbop enemies
Gene and therefore we present a real
challenge for any molecular or genomic
approach to AMR testing
and another study conducted at Mayo
assess genomic AST to perform also
favorably compared to other methods in
multi-dog-resistant pseudomonas
erogenosa isolates
then finally on the right and
highlighted in green are the results of
another internal study that's been
demonstrating the improvements in
genomic asdr teams were able to make in
a Time window of about 18 months over
the original multicentric study on the
very left
and finally before I end this excursion
into genomic ASD and conclude the
seminar here a slide that shows how
selective duration of isolate genome and
phenotypic AST data to train AI models
can contribute to an improved model
performance
the x-axis shows the inclusion of
additional data sets which can be which
we obtained for instance through
collaboration
with reference Laboratories or public
health Laboratories
the graph is showing how the inclusion
of these additional data sets for
certain passage and Drug combinations is
then leading on the y-axis to a
reduction of here very major error rates
below the regulatory threshold for ASD
IBD devices of 1.5 percent
but now switching back to the original
topic and wrapping up the seminar on
whole genome sequencing surveillance
and in conclusion
we have established that whole genome
sequencing surveillance in healthcare
settings is of high clinical utility
again it can confirm or refute
epidemiologically linked pathogens and
rapidly as well as accurately detect ha
outbreak clusters and transmission
events which in turn can guide improved
IPC action
current barriers to adoption come in the
form of high upfront equipment cost the
complex and specialized wet lab and
bioinformatics workflows required for
whole genome sequencing surveillance
and the lack of stuff trained in these
workflows
lack of access to complex yet robust and
scalable bioinformatics
and of course
in the form of the challenge that's
inherent to communicating complex
genomic information in a in a format
that is actionable from an IPC
standpoint
at option we leverage and contribute to
technological advances in order to lower
these adoption barriers with Aries ISS
we offer a rapid turnaround time send
out to Aries Labs allowing hospitals to
defer the initial upfront costs involved
in adopting whole genome sequencing
surveillance
to streamline the sample collection and
shipping through the microbiology lab we
offer fully return labeled collection
kits and protocols for critical
bacterial and fungal pathogens
end-to-end workflows for whole genome
sequencing as well as the Standalone
bioinformatics software Aries Cloud are
fully validated and provide access to
easy to use data interpretation and
actionable Reporting
our team will work with your
microbiology lab and IPC teams to
customize sample collection procedures
shipping and IPC reporting to best meet
your local requirements
all data are safely and securely stored
and backed up and Aries cloud is ready
to access your own data interpretation
and Reporting platform as soon as your
hospital is ready to bring whole genome
sequencing in-house so in summary we are
here to work with you from developing
the business case for whole genome
sequencing to establishing its utility
at your hospital and all the way to
building full and future proof on-site
capacity
and with that I would like to thank you
very much for your attention and invite
your feedback and questions
thank you Dr materno for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen and will
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for
so let's get started we've got some
great questions already coming in from
our audience here
the first question I'll start with Dr
materna asks or mentions I am excited to
hear that Eris genetics is publishing
validation protocols for the isolate
sequencing workflow to support other
labs and their adoption of NGS we are
planning to establish NGS capabilities
in our lab next year do you offer some
kind of service that would help Labs
with the setup of this or similar
workflows
it's an interesting question uh can you
hear me uh still loud and clear
yes we can excellent good yes so we are
of course happy to to share studies and
protocols and also the reference
materials we use for um for validating
our essays and we have you know our team
on standby to elaborate on these however
I need to point out that to be compliant
with regulations the actual validations
of laboratory developed tests or ldts
need to be independently carried out by
the clinical or Reference Lab that is
seeking to implement them and
um in fact to lighten that particular
burden for labs with independent access
to NGS was one of our main motivations
for publishing and sharing our
validation protocols as well as results
and reference materials and also for
supplying Aris Cloud to enable these
labs to independently generate pathogen
data with the the same level of accuracy
and the same reporting and data
interpretation features that our service
labs in Rockville and Indiana enjoy
great thank you another question I have
for you here mentions and asks we have
sequencing capabilities in-house for 16s
and we consider using the platform also
for surveillance how fast is Aeris cloud
and what price models for Aeris Cloud do
you offer
okay
um Eris Cloud scales with the samples
throughput this means regardless of
whether you analyze one or 100 isolate
whole genome data sets the the software
scales up and down compute resources on
the cloud as needed to make sure that
you obtain results in under one hour
um you can buy Iris Cloud via a simple
subscription model
and the price for a one-year
subscription is fixed so you don't
encounter any surprises
the subscription price thereby depends
um on the size and the anticipated
surveillance load of your Institution
and it covers full use of the software
including for example sequence data
analysis reporting uh The Continuous
interpretation for example of outbreak
data as well as compliance safe and
secure data storage and backup
um for detailed questions for example on
entry level pricing software trials Etc
I suggest to get in touch with us via
um the email here on on the slide or via
the contact details provided on our
website
thank you Dr materna another question I
have for you here we are currently
building a business case together with
the hospital Administration for the
adoption of WTS are there any
suggestions or lessons learned from your
customers that you can share with us
Ah that's a very good question uh in
fact and honestly with a bit of
hindsight I would assume that most
decision makers actually underestimate
on one hand the amount of outbreak
activity that is Healthcare typical
uh in their institution and on the other
hand the cost impact that these ha
outbreaks have on their budgets so
um a probably good way to assess this
impact is by conducting a pilot over
time
um and choose a time frame and a sample
volume that is representative
I would actually strongly recommend to
conduct such a pilot in a prospective
manner as this allows you to readily
assess also your procedures for sample
collection shipping as well as the
communication with your IPC teams in
real world as opposed to a theoretical
setting
I think I would further recommend to
focus on a single surveillance relevant
pathogen species for this pilot and I'm
sure your IPC team can tell you which
species is likely to cause the most ha
outbreaks at your hospital
the advantage of focusing on a single
species is that you will collect a
higher number of comparable data points
and thereby increase the statistical
power of your predictions on patient
um as well as economic impact and
benefits from whole genome sequencing
surveillance
so with a single pilot which you may
Finance for example as a research
project and with sequencing as little as
say 100 isolates you could generate
sufficient data
to inform a cost benefit analysis and
then extrapolate the results across
other Hai species
great thank you now this next question
has a few separate parts to it and I'll
go ahead and start here when comparing
similarity or Divergence of two whole
genomes how do you set the cut off or
tolerance for genetic variation is one
nucleotide difference across the whole
genome sufficient to conclude not
related or are more differences required
to conclude not related
and how do you consider the different
speeds of evolutionary clocks in
different regions of the genomes
this is a great question and very
technical focusing on on the analytics
for for cluster detection I believe so
um
while in local outbreak settings or for
some species sniff thresholds might be
sufficient this approach and this is I
think what what the the question is
addressing this approach can indeed be
imperfect in certain situations and I
think especially in large multi-year
retrospective analysis like um like for
instance big public health studies
uh there are however uh methods emerging
like for instance probabilistic
approaches such approaches
um they they still consider genetic
distance but also sample time together
with certain models for slip acquisition
over time and transmission events over
time
and then uh to base putative
transmission clusters on the probability
that the cases are separated by a
certain minimum number of transmission
events for example
certainly choosing a sufficient approach
for um you know any given species and
setting
um can be important
and also the data you gather over time
can inform the appropriate approach
great now I did see a question hop in
here in regards to obtaining the CE
credits so I just want to reiterate that
you can find those continuing education
credits in that continuing education
window that's located on the bottom of
your screen if you click there you will
be prompted to obtain those credits
All rights and we have time for a few
more questions here so we'll ask this
next one are the sequences contributing
most to resistance prediction associated
with known AMR elements or are they
lineage and or plasmid markers or
something else
uh no I I think it's um it's fair to say
that um
um the sequences and cameras that most
uh contribute to resistance prediction
are not necessarily
um always linked to known uh antibiotic
resistance genes of course
um the well-established known genes that
lead to antibiotic resistance such as
certain Transporters or
um uh for example uh you know
beta-lactamase
inhibiting genes or um
um carbop enemases Etc all can
um sorry let me catch my train of
thoughts so essentially the presence of
certain well-established resistance
genes uh will is a strong predictor in
itself and if these predictors or genes
are present they they also are
contributing to the camera profiles that
the model pick up on for resistance
prediction however
um there are many other factors genetic
factors and often these genetic factors
can be poorly
[Music]
um
are called polyvariate for instance
multiple genetic factors can occur
simultaneously in different locations
for instance in a manner that uh might
affect gene expression
um if these factors are for example
located in in Upstream regulatory
regions and considering not only
um presence absence of such factors but
their combinatory effect uh is is
important as if you think about this
from an from a essentially ecological
perspective then any mutation that you
um that you acquire can contribute
synergistically or antagonistically to
an organism's Fitness and this has to be
this all can be factored in by
predictive models which is something
that rule-based approaches cannot do and
so as a consequence I don't think it is
surprising that
um such such polyvariate genetic factors
can be very important especially in
cases where
um certain uh um known resistance genes
for example the CP negative case that I
um explained in in the presentation
where they are absent so I think it it
cannot be said that
um
that these are always associated with
AML office but I think it's it's a
fairly a fairly good mix of uh
well-known AMR genes as well as
polyvariate
um
genomic factors of course also point
mutations and such
I hope that that answered the question
if not please feel free to to reach out
to us and we can go into this in more
detail
great well thank you Dr materna we are
going to go ahead and wrap up here and
conclude our q a session today so I want
to thank you again Dr materna for your
time today and your important research
we would also like to thank Lab Rats and
our sponsor for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you have provided at
the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event so until next time
take care everyone goodbye